we've done a couple experiments with acetone and dry ice to make a
Supercooled liquid that you could freeze things in the acetone has a freezing point
Below the temperature of dry ice and so it stays liquid
But today we're gonna see what happens to put acetone in something much colder liquid, nitrogen
We'll see if our acetone will freeze solid in liquid nitrogen, and if it does freeze
We'll see if it will still ignite when we hit it with a flame to make this a little bit easier
Let's pour some of our acetone from our big can into this squeeze bottle that'll make it easier to get the acetone where we want
It to go and perhaps drip it directly into our liquid, nitrogen
There's our thermos full of liquid nitrogen so
As a first test what I want to do is fill one of these balloons
just a little bit just so the
Main pouch of the balloon is nice and full of liquid and then I'll dip that down into the liquid, nitrogen
We'll see how that goes
Yes, I'm also not 100% sure what the acetone is going to do to the latex of the balloon so that's another experiment right now
All right balloon full of acetone lowering into liquid, nitrogen
The liquid nitrogen is getting really excited and splashing up a lot
And I don't really want it to be splashing on my fingers the whole time or else start getting frostbite
Just holding it. It's getting really cold cool
just from the vapors
Fingers were too cold
It's already rigid still got liquid at the top, so I don't think we're finished freezing. We've already made some good progress
And you can still see at the very top a little bit of liquid
I think we're seeing liquid assets home inside the solid acetone
Hard to tell hard to know if the acetone is frozen or just the balloon is frozen
While that's freezing a lower and empty balloon down into the liquid nitrogen as much as I can and we'll see
What happens when the latex freezes -?
All right, so this is a balloon I
Just managed to crack it there we go now I shattered it
So that's why I'm not sure we have frozen acetone or just the frozen balloon around liquid acetone
Now it's back to just being rubber stretchy as always
I think I still here liquid shaking around in there, but I do think that we have some solid acetone as well
So I think we've got a shell of solid acetone
surrounding some liquid acetone at this point
I just got to get it to the point where it's solid all the way through that's the goal
All right our acetone inna balloon has been in the liquid nitrogen for several minutes now
So I want to take it out and try and break the balloon off of it now the balloon
Itself is going to be very brittle right now. I'm gonna try and cut it we'll see what works generally
We just want to get the balloon off of the acetone however we can
Mmm that shattered
Well, we can see inside the balloon that we definitely have
solid acetone
And balloon has begun to crack. Yeah, maybe I can peel it off
There we go whoo chunk of solid a stone, let's see if this would night pour out the extra
The acetone around it will ignite, I don't know if our little lump of frozen acetone has actually lit
I'm just gonna pour this out, ooh
We can also see that our chunk was not solid all the way through
They had a little hollow spot in the middle where it was still liquid
I think well that was interesting it looked like the frozen acetone itself didn't like to stay ignited
It melted fairly quickly and all of the melted acetone seemed like it would burn fairly easily
But the ball of frozen acetone itself really didn't seem to do too much
Let's try again
I'm just dripping acetone everywhere. That's not a good seal at all
All right a balloon is attached. Let's see if it can hold pressure
Yes can hold pressure, so now I should be able to fill with acetone without it leaking everywhere in case this over the pot
I Think that's pretty good
Rubberband is actually holding that pretty well
Now this time we're using a larger quantity of acetone
And I really want to make sure that it freezes as much as possible so to help me hold it into the acetone bath
I'm gonna tie this string around the neck and then we'll have this string coming up out of the nozzle in our thermos
Just like that
Alright, let's slowly lower
Wow that starts doing exciting things right away. Let's slowly lower the balloon into the liquid, nitrogen
We go now our balloons attached on a string
Although it might just be floating. I'm not sure about the difference in density of liquid nitrogen and acetone
There's very cold vapor on my hands alright
Let's set that aside for maybe five or ten minutes and really let that acetone freeze
While our balloon full of acetone is cooling down in the liquid nitrogen. I have another experiment
I want to try I
Have some of our acetone still left in this squeeze bottle and I'm going to see what happens if we add food coloring to it
I don't know if these two will mix or if will just sort of stay separate. Let's find out
It looks like it's mixing a little bit. It's not like what happens if you put food coloring into oil
That's I?
Think that's made some green acetone. It does look like there are little tiny flecks floating around in it now and
I'm not sure if that's something that happened with the separation of the dye
Or if there are some other contaminants inside this bottle and those picked up even more of it
But for the most part this looks like green acetone to me so here we now have a Styrofoam plate
Covered in liquid nitrogen. Let's see what happens if we drip some of our bright green colored acetone down onto it
It went right down through the liquid nitrogen onto the plate
It might be cooling down so fast that it stops eating through let's try and get a smaller amount out
One drink that's all
Our balloon filled with acetone has now been sitting in our liquid nitrogen bath for five to ten minutes
And I'm hoping that it's solidified most of the way through let's take it out, and see how it's looking
Well that's something definitely deformed a little bit
It's not quite the same round shape that it was before I want to try taking the balloon off then same thing
Let's see if we can get our little ball of acetone to light
I also might take it and after it's got the balloon off and put it back into the liquid nitrogen for a couple minutes. Oh
Something just cracked. Oh that was the balloon. I think it just shattered off
How neat
I might still have
some liquid
There we go here is our frozen acetone balloon, which is quickly?
Dripping off liquid and probably just melting so I'm going to throw it back in the liquid, nitrogen
Thinking the time that it took to move it from the pot into the liquid, nitrogen
I had melted the shape of the tongs into the sides of it
stuff heats up quickly
Now we want to pull our frozen
Acetone ball out of the liquid nitrogen put it in the pot and try and light it on fire
But so it doesn't have time to warm up as much. Let's do all of that outside with blowtorch sitting ready Oh
Our acetone has split apart well now we have several different pieces that we can try this with
Nothing
Stop coming right toward me all the time put this out with some nature infuse
Yep
All right, let's see the piece. We do here at this time
Let's see the metal of the tongs is just melting right down through it
It's just making my hand cold I
Have to say I'm a little disappointed that we can't light this on fire
Well there you have it the results of freezing acetone in liquid, nitrogen
It definitely freezes it turns into a hard solid material. I was a little disappointed that we couldn't get it to light on fire
while it was still in its frozen State
He did melt very quickly and the melted acid home was very easy to light on fire of course
But frozen acetone sadly does not seem to burn acetone may not burn very well while it's in its frozen state
But it's still pretty useful stuff including if you want to make your own supercooled liquid, but don't have access to liquid nitrogen
Remember if you have a bath of acetone with a lot of dry ice in it
You can get it down to over a hundred degrees Fahrenheit below zero. That's cold enough to freeze a lot of stuff
Thank you for joining us for this video as part of our never-ending quest to dunk every known substance in the liquid, nitrogen
Remember to come gear yourself up with products and merch at the king of random calm. See you there
Now one more thing that I am going to try even though. It's maybe not the wisest
acetone has a fairly low burn point so I've got some insulated gloves on and
I'm just gonna see if I can light my hands on fire with it
Just a little bit
There we go
That was fun smart maybe not fun no of course not never try that it's not fun at all
Hey guys, thanks so much for caring about our content our channel so much
It really is amazing have great people like you
Jumping in to watch every new video that gets uploaded and watching it to the end you really are amazing we appreciate that